hey if you let's support the production
of more Maloof university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on Louvre University calm
thanks and enjoy if you recall from part
5 we talked about palmitate synthesis
and we made palmitate which was a 16
carbon saturated fatty acid question is
what if we wanted a longer saturated
fatty acid what we do is we would just
have to lengthen palmitate and at the
length and palmitate by adding acetyl
groups which are going to be two carbons
each of course and this would be done
via the fatty acid elongation system
oops
elongation
system abbreviated as fa es where are
these systems located which cellular
organelle well they'd be located in the
ER the endoplasmic reticulum there's two
ers though right the smooth ER and the
rough ER which one would this happen in
we're talking about fatty acid synthesis
which is lipid synthesis so that would
be in the smooth ER the rough ER has
ribosomes and it is involved in protein
synthesis right so that's not what we're
talking about here this can also occur
to some extent in the mitochondria as
well okay so how does it work
well let's imagine that we have palma
telco a right which we we've made and
it's a 16 carbon fatty acyl coa and we
can show the numbers here if you like
there's 16 carbons there let's say we
want to lengthen it to stereo Co a which
is 2 carbons longer at 18 carbons what
do we need to do what we need to add to
a 2 carbon unit right and that 2 carbon
unit a 2 carbon steel unit is coming
from Melanie oak away just like it did
from fatty acid synthesis right Melanie
Oh a is the two carbon acetyl group
donor right just like it is in fatty
acid synthesis and there's a
condensation reaction in fatty acid
synthesis where Melanie Alcoa comes in
with the existing a so CO a they
condense and off comes a carbon dioxide
that that gets rid of one carbon right
Melanie okay way starting with three
carbons we lose one we effectively added
to two carbons that's of course that in
the condensation reaction and in fatty
acid synthesis what follows the
condensation reaction is the first
reduction and then then it's followed by
a dehydration and then it's followed by
a second reduction and we get a a an
acetyl should be an a so CO a that's
just two carbons longer and that's
essentially what's happening here so
these are going to be the same reactions
as as fatty acid synthesis but in this
fatty acid you
Gatien system it's just different
enzymes that accomplish them and of
course these reactions there are details
that I'm omitting here because if you
are familiar with these reactions from
fatty acid synthesis you should kind of
know what's going on here well the
intermediates are and things like that I
don't want to spend time talking about
it here because that should be previous
knowledge from that other video so
definitely watch that if you haven't
already so but what happens here is that
we're essentially just lengthening this
chain so one key difference is that we
have different enzymes another
difference is that in in this here the
acyl carrier is this coenzyme a here
right so we have coenzyme a right but
the acyl carrier in fatty acid synthesis
was the acyl carrier protein the acp on
the fatty acid synthase complex right so
that's not a difference notice here just
just so I can be clear is that the two
carbons that are added in the acetyl
group are added to this end right to
this end is where the acetyl group is at
is hence hence the green portion here
right that's important to remember for
the next video and let's talk about that
in just a second but keep that in mind
okay so that's how it works so we think
about the overview of what's going on
here we can take palmitate and have a
round tube elongation occur to go from a
16 carbon saturated fatty acid to serie
which is an 18 carbon saturated fatty
acid right we just added two carbons
if we have another round of elongation
we can go from an 18 carbon saturated
fatty acid to a 20 carbon saturated
fatty acid in a rack a date right and
again these numbers are labeling the
carbons and this can continue right we
can have more rounds of elongation to
give us other long-chain saturated fatty
acids one important thing to note though
is that this is only going to be able to
give us long chain saturated fatty acids
saturated fatty acids what if we wanted
or needed unsaturated versions of any of
these fatty acids well then we'd have to
have a process called desaturation occur
that's what the next video is on
okay so I hope to see you there and
thank you for watching thanks for
watching please don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share the video
with anyone who you think might find it
helpful thanks and happy studying